في المقابل قال المتحدث باسم قوات الجنوب
في الجيش الروسي ان قوات بلاده عززت
مواقعها في دنيا
القوات الروسيه مواقعها على طول خط مواجهه
في منطقه
وحدات من قوات الجنوب بالتعاون مع
الطائرات الحربيه والمدفعيه 5 هجمات شنتها
مجموعات هجوميه تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
قرب بخموت فضلا عن ثلاث هجمات في مارينكا
وقضي على اكثر من 250 جنديا اوكرانيا ودمر
عدد من الاليات العسكريه بينها منظومه
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات وعدد من مدافعها
للمتابعه معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك عميد
حنا اذا كيف تقول انها اخترقت خط الدفاع
الاول لروسيا في زابوروجيا اذا صح هذا
الكلام هل يعني ان الدفاع الروسيه في هذه
المنطقه بات في خطر فعلا على اعتبار ان
الخط الاول يكون الاكثر تحصينا
سهام ما خرقته القوات الاوكرانيه هو
حقول الالغام وهنا اعتمدت استراتيجيه او
تكتيك جديد عبر استعمال وحدات مشاه قليله
نزع الالام يدويا وبالتالي الهجوم على
الخنادق وحتى على الحفر المضاده للدبابات
اليوم نتحدث عن عمق يقارب 30 كلم سهام
يعني اليوم الوصول الى روبوتين يحتم
الوصول او حتى الانحراف نحو
نقاط الضعف الاهم يعني تتبع نقاط الضعف
الاساسيه المهم اليوم ان نصل الى توكماك
وبالتالي الى وهذا امر طويل جدا من هنا
الحديث دائما ان هذا التقدم اذا استمر
الدعم والصناعه المحليه الاوكرانيه
للسلاح والذخيره قد يذهب الى العام
2025/2024 فاذا نحن في مرحله اوليه وهذا
الخرق لا يؤشر الى خرق كبير لانه
الدفاعات
الروسيه كان لها الوقت الكافي للاستعداد
تحدثت عن الصناعه المحليه والان هناك ايضا
تاكيد من كياف ان حصلت على صواريخ
بريطانيه وفرنسيه بعيده المدى ما الذي
يغيره هذا في قدرات اوكرانيا وبالتالي في
مسار هذه الحرب
سهام اوكرانيا حاليا بعد التجربه تبين
انها تعتمد استراتيجيه تقوم على ثلاث
ابعاد اساسيه في البعد التكتيكي كما قلنا
بروبوتين وغيرها يعني قتال بعناصر صغيره
نزع الالغام يدويا وبالتالي لاحداث الخرق
المستوى الثاني هو القصف البعيد المدى
وهنا ياتي اهميه الصواريخ التي تحدثت عنها
لحرمان القوات الروسيه من اللوجستيه عبر
قصف قواعد
مخازن الذخيره القياده والسيطره وحتى
الجسور لعزل عن بعضها البعض والمستوى
الثالث هو المسيرات لنقل الارض او الحرب
الى الارض الروسيه من ضمن مبدا المعامله
بالمثل وللقول الاوكرانيين وغيرهم اننا
نحن قادرون مثل روسيه لنقل الحرب الى
الارض الروسيه هنا ياتي في البعد الثاني
هذه الصواريخ سكالب او حتى ستورم شادو
واليوم يتم الحديث عن طائرات الاف 16 مع
صواريخ الهاربون التي تطلق من الجو نحو
البحر وهنا ياتي دور واهميه الاسطول
البحري الروسي في البحر الاسود شكرا لك
العميد الياس حناء الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من بيروت الان